you've got a fanbase now pretty rabid
fan base then they post pictures of you
with people they think are your
look-alikes online man they'd been doing
it and that's all my social media my
that's but that's a sign that you're
that you really get in place okay stop
like they can't stop sending them
everybody keeps sending them all some of
them are complimentary like there's this
one
Idris Elba they said that you they said
you look like eat yourself and I thought
well that's a compliment
not able spot on on this one yeah but
there are some where you think that it's
not is it's not as good oh hell nah man
look we got some more dough yeah I think
yes that's absolutely I'm sorry I don't
know who's who Hey look like Richard
Simmons yeah they keep doing it and and
oh stop
it's hotter one here this hey you
weren't happy there for a while I
remember that I remember that I like out
a white people
oh and right now
oh no that's funny that's funny they put
up one of the two of us I think you made
many appearances on my show just any
random white guy with another random guy
with a bird on his shoulder yes they
keep they do that all the time